The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
if visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So this is
review session number five,
I guess it is.
And it comes before
an exam next Tuesday,
and actually there'll be a
further review session number
six on Monday, right
before the exam.
So maybe today we would,
there's a homework problem set
on Chapter 2, mostly
the oscillating masses
and springs and today's
lecture that you
see traces of, networks.
And masses and springs
also the static case.
So I'm open as
always to questions.
Yes please, thank you?
AUDIENCE: 2.2 number six.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
2.2, number six.
OK.
Yeah.
So this is, and of course you
understand that, so I'm happy,
that's a good
question to discuss.
And maybe number
seven people well
have something to say about.
Good.
So that just fine, so let
me start right in on those.
So, number six is
the fact, I mean
everybody understands that
when energy is conserved,
that's an important thing.
And so the question is first
when is energy conserved
in the differential equations?
In the equation we're
trying to solve?
And if it is, then
we want to know,
we would like to choose
difference methods that
also conserve energy.
They may not be exactly
right, they may not be exactly
at a right point on this circle,
if we're in that model problem,
but still on the circle.
So, and the point is that
the trapezoidal method does
stay on the circle, and
of course the differential
equation stays on the circle.
Can I, so, and I put quite
a bit into this problem six.
So this is 2.2.6, and and let
me try say something about that,
OK.
So, first of all, there's the
continuous problem. du/dt=Au.
When does that conserve energy?
And then there's the
discrete problem,
which we know that Euler's
doesn't conserve energy,
because we've seen it, the
computer shows you right away.
It spirals up from
the circle, it
spirals in, or forward
and backward, or whatever.
But trapezoidal method, is
that the one that turns out
to be well?
OK, so it refers to equation
24 as the trapezoidal method,
and let me try to
follow that notation.
Yep. the trapezoidal
method is this one.
Did we get music there for
the trapezoidal method?
OK. u_(n+1) equal
(I+A*delta t/2)u_n.
OK.
Right.
So that, and actually
problem seven,
that you maybe want
to discuss too,
is the question of how
accurate this is compared
to the differential equation.
Everybody should see that
this really came from,
the original way to look at
this was (u_(n+1)-u_n)/delta t,
that approximated
the derivative,
equals A and then I'm
taking half at u--
at the new time and
half at the old time.
So it's got that centering.
That we suspect will give
us a little extra accuracy.
OK.
So two questions then.
One was the stability,
so problem six
was the energy conserved,
and problem 2.2.7,
if I anticipate it, is
the order of accuracy.
So these are both
topics that are
extremely important in
choosing a difference method.
We would like to know first
when is energy conserved there?
What differential equations
have conserved energy?
Physically we kind of
can see them coming.
If a physical universe
is not being-- Somehow,
lots of physical problems, we
see those masses and springs
oscillating, and we
say OK, nothing's
coming in from outside,
how could-- Energy
there would be the sum of the
kinetic energy of the masses,
and the potential
energy in the springs.
So energy passes
between kinetic,
when the mass is zooming
past equilibrium,
and potential energy, when the
mass is stretching the spring.
So we've got two cases.
And we would hope, and
this trapezoidal method
comes through, that
energy is conserved.
So can I just begin
with this one?
Maybe I always ought to say,
because you guys are also
thinking about the quiz.
So, for example, this
question about how
to find the order of accuracy,
I'll speak about that.
but let me just say
that's not something
that we've done in enough
detail that I would
expect you to be
quick on the quiz
and just be able to do it out.
I'll try to choose
questions on the exam
that you really have
had more practice with.
But this is certainly important,
so it was that definitely right
to put on the homework.
And this is important.
OK, so let me tackle this one.
First the differential equation.
So by energy here I'm meaning
just the length of u squared.
So now I'm looking at
energy conserved, OK.
So I'm hoping energy
conserved would
mean that the derivative
of u squared was zero.
That's what conserving
energy would mean.
And my question is
which differential
equations-- What's the
condition on A, in other words?
How would I recognize
from this matrix A
that I have this
interesting property?
OK.
So, let me just show
you what I would do.
Another way to write u
squared is u transposed u.
These are vectors, of course.
So what's the derivative
of u transpose u?
My equation is telling me what
the derivative of u is here,
I've got the thing squared.
OK.
I have a product here, right?
I've u's times u's.
So I'm going to
use the standard--
They happen to be vectors, so
if I want to use like freshman
calculus, I'd have to
get down to the scalar
to get down to the
numbers, but I absolutely
could do that and just
follow them along, component
by component.
Or I could try to do it
a whole column at a time.
And let me try that.
It's going to be the
product rule, right?
In some form I'll have this guy
times the derivative of this
plus the derivative,
I'll keep them
in order, the derivative of
this thing, times this guy.
Right?
That's the product rule.
OK, now what do I know here?
I know that the
du/dt is Au, right?
So this is u transposed Au.
And I know du, is that
dt meant to be dt?
So du/dt is Au, again.
Look, this isn't difficult.
It's (Au) transpose u.
And the question is,
when is this zero, OK?
So those were the two terms
from the product rule,
and notice they're
not exactly the same.
This is u transpose Au,
and what's this guy?
u transpose A transpose u.
So if I put them
together, I have
u transpose times the A and
the A transpose times u.
And I'm hoping that this will
be zero, for all the solutions
that I've come up with.
So the condition is
simply that A plus A--
we want that to be the zero
matrix, A plus A transpose.
In other words, if A
transpose is minus A,
that's the good one.
If A transpose is
minus A, this is
zero, that's zero,
that's zero, that's
zero, energy's conserved.
So the energy is conserved
when A transpose is minus
A. It's for the anti-symmetric
A's that energy is conserved.
And of course this
all makes sense.
What are the special solutions
to that differential equation?
The special solutions to this
equation are e to the, just,
this is connecting now with
things that really are basic.
The special solutions,
the pure eigensolutions,
the ones that follow
their own paths,
are the e^(lambda*t)x's, right?
Where x is an eigenvector of
A, and lambda's an eigenvalue.
Those are the guys, and we
expect to have n of them,
and we expect a
combination of those
to give us the general solution
and to match the boundary
conditions.
So these are the,
these n of these guys
with n different eigenvectors
and their eigenvalues
are the heart of
problems like this.
And of course that's the
additional homework problem
that wasn't in the book but I
added as an additional problem
was exactly that, to
get you to practice
with these eigenvectors
and eigenvalues.
OK, now, what's the
deal, I want to connect
this energy conserving with
this picture of solutions.
When would this keep
the same energy?
When would this have constant
energy, constant length?
The length would be constant,
since x is certainly,
that's an eigenvector,
whatever it is.
This is what's changing.
And now I want to know, when
does the length not change?
Well, the test would be
that this number should
have absolute value one, right?
If this keeps absolute
value one, then
in the eigenvalue picture I
have energy staying the same.
OK?
Now, when will this
have magnitude one?
Time is running along, this
is e to the lambda t, so which
lambdas?
Zero, certainly, but
now there's more,
you gotta know the others.
What other lambdas
will have, what
other lambdas give me this
thing stays on the unit
circle, absolute value one?
Key question you must
know. lambda could be?
Imaginary. lambda
could be imaginary;
right, lambda
could be imaginary.
e^(i*omega*t).
That's just like basic
fact about complex numbers,
that if lambda's imaginary we
would have cosine of something
t plus i times the
sine of something t,
cos squared plus sine
squared being one,
we'd be on the unit circle.
So from this picture we
would want the lambdas
to be pure imaginary.
And now a little
next step, what we'd
like for eigenvectors, because
the real solution will not
be just one of these
guys but a combination.
So when we have a combination
each one is doing its thing,
each one better have
lambda imaginary
but more than that, we
would want the x's to be
perpendicular.
Because if the x's interact,
then this guy, one of these,
you will say there's
only one there,
but I'm thinking
of n of them there.
A combination of
say, two of them.
Suppose I have an
e^(lambda_1 t)*x_1,
and an e^(lambda_2*t)*x_2,
when does that conserve energy?
Well, each one will, but
the combination will be fine
if the x's are perpendicular.
Because if I have
perpendicular vectors,
then the length of the whole
combination by Pythagoras
is just one squared
and the other squared
and each of those
pieces is constant.
Let me say what
I'm trying to say.
That the eigenvalue,
eigenfunction picture
also tells us that we would
like imaginary eigenvalues
and perpendicular eigenvectors.
And that is exactly what you get
from A transpose equal minus A.
So A transpose equal
minus A is exactly,
those matrices,
anti-symmetric matrices,
have perpendicular eigenvectors,
just like symmetric,
but the eigenvalues
are pure imaginary.
Instead of all being real,
they're all pure imaginary.
In other words, that
answer and the discussion
here came to the
same conclusion,
that A should be anti-symmetric.
OK.
Now let me look at--
Is that OK, so that's
a discussion which
is worth knowing
about differential equations.
When is energy conserved.
Now I want to do,
or the problem asks
me to do, what about
this difference equation?
When is energy conserved there?
And I believe it
will be, this is
the requirement for the
differential equation
to be OK, to conserve energy
and so I'm going to expect,
I'm going to need
that in this one.
And is that enough?
If I have this A transpose
equal minus A, anti-symmetric,
it was good for this, does
it also do the job here?
Is this trapezoidal
method just cool
so that it will
conserve energy, too.
And the answer, I think,
is yes, and the problem
was to prove it, or to see why.
So what do I now want?
If you don't mind
my erasing, I'm
now going to look
at the discrete guy.
So now I'm looking at when
is u_(n+1) squared equal u_n
squared?
That's what I mean by conserving
energy in the discrete case.
At every step, same energy.
So now I want to look at the
energy in u_(n+1) compared
to the energy in u_n, and I
want to see that this holds.
Probably, there's some
smart way to do that.
Now we're down to just
the math questions.
Math is always looking for
some, you just sort of do
the right thing, you stand
back and poof it works.
OK, so what's the right thing?
Hopefully I have
helped you and me
by saying what would be
a good idea to do here.
Can I just look?
OK, it say, oh, does
it say what to do?
Yeah.
It says multiply by u_(n+1)+u_n.
Take the dot product,
that's interesting.
so why did that work?
Take the dot product of
both sides with u_(n+1)-u_n.
Did anybody succeed
with this idea?
But that's the idea.
And hopefully we'll
get it to work.
That if I multiply both sides
by u_(n+1), oh, no, plus u_n.
Maybe better if I
look at it this way.
I'm sort of OK to
do it that way.
Suppose I multiply both sides.
So now I'm following on
this idea, That equation
I've rewritten here and without
practice I don't know which one
is the good one to start with.
But I'm pretty OK with
starting with this one.
So what's my idea?
That's my equation, now I'm
going to multiply both sides
by (u_(n+1)+u_n) transpose.
Now I don't have room
to do it, unfortunately.
I want to stick in here
u_(n+...) with a plus sign
in there, and of course I have
to do the same thing here.
OK.
Are you OK, do you
see what I'm doing?
I want to show that
this equation, which
is the same as this equation,
has this property which
is a copy of this property.
Here would be
another way to do it.
We could do it,
the way we're going
to do it now sort of compares
with the way we started
with the derivative
of the norm squared.
I could also ask
the same question
by following eigenvectors.
I could also ask
the same question
by following eigenvectors.
I'm guessing that here the
eigenvalues-- u_(n+1) is,
you see I could do it both ways.
Maybe having just
done eigenvectors
let me do this one
by eigenvectors.
So an eigenvector of
A, when it's x itself,
is, what happens
to an eigenvector.
Suppose u_0 is an eigenvector
x of A, What's u_1?
Yeah, you really should
see this question.
So u_0 is the eigenvector
x, then what is u_1?
Let me just write it here.
Ax equaling lambda*x.
So these are the
eigenvalues of A,
and we've learned that they're
pure imaginary in this case
when we're ready
to go, and now I'd
like to know that we
get the good thing here.
OK, so if u_n is an
eigenvector, what is u_(n+1)?
OK, so can I just
do that? u_(n+1) is,
so what do I have on that right
hand side? x and what is Ax?
It's lambda, right?
It's lambda*x.
So all this is one plus
lambda delta t on two x
but now I've also
got to bring this guy
over here, its inverse.
And see what that does.
Now it's the inverse,
so it's going
to have the same eigenvector
and the eigenvalue's
going to go in the
denominator and it'll
be one minus lambda
delta t over two.
OK, so that's u_(n+1).
Do you see what's
happening here?
The eigenvector x, if we
start with that eigenvector x,
we come out with
a multiple of x.
And this is the multiple.
So each finite difference
step multiplies by a number
just the way each, in
the continuous case
we were multiplying
by e to the lambda t
and in the discrete
step by step case
we're multiplying
by that number.
Actually, this is why
problem seven is important,
because if we want to know how
accurate the comparison is I
want to compare e to the
lambda t with that number.
So problem six is asking a
question about that ratio.
And problem seven is
asking another question
about that very same ratio.
Now what's the question
for problem six?
When will this vector have
the same length as-- This
x was u_n.
So I started with the u_n,
I multiplied by this number
to get u_(n+1), when do
they have the same length?
When that number has
absolute value one.
So if I'm watching
eigenvectors, this guy
had absolute value one
because lambda was imaginary.
Now, what about
this guy? lambda's
still that same
lambda, imaginary.
What can you tell
me about one plus,
so lambda is some i*omega, delta
t over two and down here I have
one minus i*omega, that's
the lambda, delta t over two.
I believe that that does
have absolute value one.
Anybody tell me why?
So this is checking
that energy is
conserved for each eigenvector.
The energy-- Because the
eigenvector is multiplied
by that number and
that's some number,
it's some complex
number, but I believe
it has absolute value one and
I believe you can tell me why.
Yep.
Because they're
complex conjugates.
This numerator and the
denominator are complex
conjugates, in the complex
plane here's the one,
and I go up by
i*omega*delta t over two,
or on this one I go down by--
Bu those lengths are the same.
That numerator, the
length of the numerator
is that guy, the length of
the denominator is this guy,
and their ratio is one.
So I think that this
gives us the point
about complex numbers.
That a complex number
and its conjugate
automatically have
ratio of magnitude one.
You see the difference
between Euler's method.
So Euler's method, so
forward Euler-- Forward Euler
would not have had this
stuff on the left side.
It would all have been
on the right-hand side.
Forward Euler would have
been about i plus A*delta t.
Delta t A. And what
are its eigenvalues?
One plus i omega delta t, right?
With no, we're not
dividing by anybody.
This part is up top too, so
it's one plus i*omega*delta t.
Now, does that have
absolute value one?
Well, you know from the way
I'm asking the question, what
can you tell me about
the absolute value
of the forward
Euler growth factor?
Greater than one.
Because this is the one, and
this is the i*omega*delta t,
maybe went up twice as far.
And there was
nobody to divide by.
It's bigger than
one, so it blows up.
And the backward Euler had
only the one over one minus
i*omega*delta t, so the backward
was like this, one over it.
And less than one.
But this balance has
absolute value equal one.
So, OK, that's the sort of
heart of what's going on.
Can I, before I tackle the
question using the hint there,
which would take me
on another blackboard,
can I discuss question seven?
Were you going to ask
me about number seven?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was.
PROFESSOR STRANG: You were?
OK.
Alright.
We get the answer.
So, question seven is
about the accuracy.
So here's the correct number,
this is my e^(i*omega*t),
that's the correct number that
I should be multiplying by.
And the actual number that I'm
multiplying by is that much.
Or, in the forward Euler
case, it's that one.
And so I'm comparing
the one step accuracy.
So let me compare
one step accuracy.
So this is the topic now,
of order of accuracy.
This is question seven.
And it amounts to comparing
the-- So what is one delta t
step in the continuous case?
So how much does
the eigenvector x,
what does it get multiplied
by if I take a delta t
step in the
differential equation?
So this is the
exact delta t step,
what the finite difference
won't get exactly right.
So the exact step delta t.
The differential equation, and
of course I'm always looking
at Ax=lambda*x, the differential
equation multiplies x by what?
What's the exact growth
factor, you could say,
if my equation is du/dt=Au,
that's the differential
equation, and I'm supposing
that I'm on an eigenvector x,
so that the solution
is e^(i*omega*t),
or e^(i*lambda*x).
Now, what happened
over a delta t step?
This is the answer like
running along for all time,
all I'm asking you to
do is if the step is
delta t, what's that number?
I mean that number is telling us
how much it grew in that delta
t step, and of course
it's e^(i*omega*delta t).
That's the exact growth
factor, that's G_exact.
In one time step,
the eigenvector
gets multiplied by that, because
that's the amount of time that
elapsed.
And what's the
approximate growth,
the growth factor
from trapezoidal
is just what we wrote down here.
One plus lambda*delta t, maybe
I'll stay with lambda rather
than i*omega.
e^(lambda*delta t), and this
was one plus delta t over two
lambda, divided by one minus
delta t over two lambda.
So question seven just says
compare that with that.
Thinking of delta t as a small
time step, if delta t is zero,
then of course e
to the zero is one,
if delta t is zero
I get one here,
they're correct if delta t
is zero, that's no big deal.
How do I understand what
happens for small delta t?
I'm comparing this exponential
for a small delta t
with this guy for
a small delta t.
How do you make comparisons
for a small delta t?
Well, that's what Taylor
series is all about.
Let's do the Taylor series.
What's the series
for the exponential?
If delta t is small, I have
e to some little number,
tell me, start me out
on the exponential.
One, thanks, one plus,
lambda*delta t plus,
this is the exponential series,
there are only two series
in this world that
are worth knowing.
Really, that's literally true.
In calculus you study all
these infinite series,
there are two that
are important,
that are worth remembering
long after calculus.
And e to the x, e to the
whatever, is one of them.
OK, what's the next term?
Over two, lambda delta
t squared over two,
and then there's a cube guy
if you don't mind telling me
what's the denominator
in that one?
It's three factorial six.
Good.
And onward.
OK.
So that's one of the series
that everybody should know.
OK, how we going to
deal with this guy?
We want to expand that,
so what's my goal?
I want you to expand that
in powers of lambda*delta t
and compare with this.
And see where, they aren't
going to be equal, right?
At some point they're
going to be different.
But at least they
should start out equal.
So so here's the heart
of problem seven.
How do I expand this
in powers of delta t?
Do you mind if I
just, this is just
a number let me put it times
one over, so this is times one
minus delta t over two
lambda, inverse right?
I just bring that
up as a number.
So it's this guy times
one over this guy.
What do I do?
This is, here's the moment
when the math tools get used.
And I'm well aware
that it's like years
since you did calculus
or series or whatever,
and those tools get rusty.
And the point is that
they're really genuine tools
that we can now use.
So what do you think?
This is the problem one,
this is the one coming from
the denominator;
this is 1/(1-x).
So I have a 1/(1-x) deal.
And what's the series for that?
I said there were two
series worth remembering,
and sure enough the
exponential was one of them
and now we're ready
for the other one.
What's the series for that guy?
1+x, good start.
Plus x squared.
Right, x squared plus
x cubed and so on.
Real simple.
It's all the same stuff
with no factorials.
Those are the two
series to know.
The exponential series
and the geometric series.
Right, that's the
geometric series.
OK, so that's what I've
got out of this stuff.
Can I write it below?
I have one plus delta
t over two lambda.
Let me just call that
x for the moment.
Delta t over two lambda is my x.
One plus x, and this is 1/(1-x),
which you just told me is one
plus x plus x squared
plus x cubed and so on.
And now I've got to do
that multiplication.
OK, x is, remember this is
x, I'm just saving space.
Can you multiply those guys?
So that's one plus x
times a lot of stuff here.
What do I have all together?
Well, the one,
what's the next term?
Two x's?
Everybody spots
the two x's there?
And then the next term, you
have to get these terms right
because we plan to
compare with this guy
and see how many we get.
How many x squareds
are in there?
Is it two?
Looks like two.
Two x squareds.
And two x cubes, and so on.
Yeah, that looks right, OK.
Now I'm ready, what
am I ready for?
I'm ready to say what x is, x
is this delta t over two lambda.
So what have I got here, one?
What is this guy now?
Two x's is delta t lambda.
Is this good?
Yes, right?
We're pleased.
Because the two x
is the, two of these
is delta t lambda and that's
what we wanted to match.
Absolutely.
Delta t lambda, lambda delta t.
Now let's keep going.
By the way if this first
term hadn't matched
we would be extremely surprised.
Because that first
matching is only
saying that my difference
equation is quite consistent,
it's a reasonable creation out
of the differential equation.
And we knew that.
The question is how much
further are we going to get?
Euler will not get any further.
With Euler the next
ones will fail.
But I think with trapezoidal
the next ones are going to work.
Does it work?
It's like we're holding
our breath, right?
Two now, I'm going
to put in x squared
and see about this
term. x is what?
x is this guy, delta
t over two lambda.
Delta t lambda
over two, squared.
And now you get the fun.
Because you're going to
compare this term with what?
With this term.
And are they the same?
Yes.
So that's the way,
you see, that you
got the extra accuracy which
Euler did not give you,
but that's why the
trapezoidal rule is
a is a second order
accurate method.
OK, you may say that I went
overboard to say all that.
You may say I didn't
ask that question.
But it's the right question to
ask about order of accuracy,
and it's what problem seven
was intending to bring.
Maybe I called it h in problem
seven rather than x here.
Well.
Oh gosh, I realize
I I'm supposed
to come back to this one.
But some people might
have other problems
that they're interested in.
But let me, because
time is pushing along,
and the solution to
this one we'll post,
let me at least offer
the possibility to ask me
about something completely,
not six or seven here,
but something
entirely different,
like what's the first question
on the quiz or anything.
And that, let me say I'll
hope to know by Tuesday.
I love to teach, but making
up exams is serious work.
Anyway.
Let me open a board and open to
another question of any sort.
Any place, Chapter 1,
Chapter 2, whatever.
Is there anything?
So I know that you're in
the middle of this homework.
So I can say a little
more here about
that number six if you want,
but I wanted to allow, yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR STRANG: The
A, from today's lecture
this was the incidence
matrix, and this
was the A transpose A
that's probably still
on the board somewhere.
Yep.
So this is the A, which
you should take in and be
able to create if I
gave you the graph,
and this is the A
transpose A, so it's
through today's lecture, yeah.
Next lecture I'll be talking
about the A transpose
by itself, which involves
Kirchhoff's current law,
it's beautiful.
A transpose w equals zero.
But I think this part was
straightforward enough
to be able to add this
to our list of problems
which fit the framework.
So that's what that was about.
It doesn't mean that this will
be on but it could be, right.
OK, what else?
You guys are patient, I
come on-- Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yep.
AUDIENCE: This is only valid
when x is less than one?
PROFESSOR STRANG: It's only
valid when x is less than one,
so that's now the math point
that this expansion for e^x
valid for all x's.
Because you're dividing by
these bigger and bigger numbers.
But this one is only
valid up to x=1.
At x=1 we're getting
one plus one plus one,
and we're getting one
over one minus one,
sort of infinity
matches infinity,
but then if x goes up to two,
yeah what happens if x is two?
It's sort of not good,
but you know mathematics,
it's never completely
crazy, right?
If x is two, what does this say?
What have I got on
the left hand side?
Negative one.
And what have I got on
the right hand side?
One plus two plus
four plus eight.
I should not allow
this to be videotaped,
but that's actually not
so completely crazy.
In some nutty way that
could still make some sense.
That's certainly will not be
on the-- So you're right that x
should be less than one, and
of course it will be here
because I'm looking
at little delta t's.
Little, so my delta t-- My x
was this thing and my delta t,
the time step was small
and somehow that tells me,
actually this is
a good indication.
It gives me the units.
That stability and
things going right
will depend on lambda delta t.
Will depend on lambda delta t,
that's the key parameter there.
That's like the
dimensionless parameter
that we're, or lambda delta
t over two, or whatever.
But lambda delta t is the key.
And a highly important key.
It tells us that as
lambda gets bigger,
as the matrix has
bigger eigenvalues,
delta t has got to get smaller.
And I mentioned stiff equations.
Stiff equations are equations
where the eigenvalues lambda
are out of scale.
You know, you might have two
eigenvalues, one of size one
and the other of size
ten to the fourth,
because you've got two
physical processes going on
at the same time.
And those equations are
tough, because that ten
to the fourth guy is
forcing your delta t
to be really small.
Whereas the action
might, the true,
real solution might be
controlled by the lambda=1 guy.
So to follow this
slow evolution,
you're having to take very small
steps because on top of that
slow evolution
with the lambda=1,
there's some very fast evolution
maybe with lambda equal minus
10,000.
Yeah, there's a
lot happening here.
And always you have
to think OK, is there
some way around that box.
Because forward Euler
would not get you through.
OK, thanks for that question,
you got another one?
OK.
AUDIENCE: So then if you
weren't using small enough time
steps, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR STRANG: If you weren't
using small enough time steps,
OK.
For trapezoidal, let's say?
AUDIENCE: I mean, that
expansion wouldn't hold
if you were using a lambda--
PROFESSOR STRANG: Well,
the expansion is really
intended for a small delta t.
Yeah.
It's not intended, I never
added up the whole series.
I just compared a couple of
terms to see how am I doing,
and I got the extra term
to match from trapezoidal
that I didn't get from Euler.
So what's to say?
If you took delta
t too big, what
would happen in the
trapezoidal method?
Well, you would
stay on this circle
because the absolute value
of this thing is truly one.
Even if lambda is enormous
and delta t is way too big,
we still had complex conjugates
and their ratio was one.
So we would not
leave the circle,
at least in perfect
arithmetic, as everybody says.
If we didn't make
any round-off error,
we would not leave the circle.
But boy would we skip all
over the place on that circle.
So if we took
delta t too big, we
would be completely inaccurate.
We wouldn't be unstable,
for trapezoidal,
because it would
stay on the circle,
but the phase would be
completely wrong, yeah.
So it would be a complex
number of absolute value one,
but it would not be close
to the exact growth factor.
Well, so many things to say.
I realize that the course
moves along pretty quickly
but this topic of numerical
methods for differential
equations, that's a
core part of 18.086.
So I'm like anticipating here
in just a couple of days what
really takes longer is the
stability and the accuracy
and the best choices for
time-dependent problems.
OK, always good questions.
Anything else that's on
your mind of any sort?
Yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR STRANG: 114?
AUDIENCE: There is a figure 2.7.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
OK.
114 figure 2.7.
Oh yes, OK.
Oh yes.
AUDIENCE: I figure it's about
how these shapes [INAUDIBLE].
see.
That has a bunch of
figures, so that in order
to say for everybody who's
not looking at the book,
those figures are about the
problem we've discussed here
with a model problem,
where we're on a circle.
So do I have space
to draw a circle?
Well, let me just
make space here.
OK, so page 114 has
that model problem
that we've drawn before.
There's the exact solution,
here's the phase plane;
there's u and there's
u', and the u was cos(t),
so the u' was minus sin(t), and
we travel around the circle.
On the exact solution.
Energy constant, u squared
stays one-- u squared
plus u prime squared stay one.
Now which figure was it
you wanted me to look at?
So.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Of any of them?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
OK, that's fine.
Let's see.
Is trapezoidal on that one?
Yeah.
Trapezoidal was the first one.
OK, so figure 2.6 shows
the trapezoidal method
moving around the circle.
So what happens?
Yeah, thanks, that's a
very suitable question.
OK. and I took, in that figure
I took, how long does it
take for the exact solution
to get exactly back
where it started?
At t equal what do I come back?
AUDIENCE: 2pi.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
t equal to 2pi,
I'm right back where I was.
Right?
Cosine has period 2pi.
OK, now a single
step of size 2pi
would be really
ridiculous, right?
I mean, I want to now delta t.
So in that figure I took delta
t to be 2pi divided by 32.
So I'm taking delta
t to be the 2pi, that
would bring me all the way
around, but I'm dividing by 32.
So, what does that mean?
What what does the exact
solution do at those steps?
32 steps?
It goes on the circle,
32 equal steps, 30, 360,
2pi divided by 32 radians
every time, comes back exactly
there, the exact solution.
And right where I started.
So it's like following a planet.
Now I do it by
finite differences.
So now I'm going to follow
the trapezoidal rule,
just what we've been talking
about, with that time step,
and with the equation--
Everybody remembers
the equation was [u, u'] equals,
do you remember what the matrix
was in that equation?
This is the derivative of
it and this is [u, u'].
Sorry to squeeze this in,
but what I'm, u' is u'.
u'' is minus u.
Now we know why that
matrix was good, right?
Why is that?
That's my matrix
A, why is it good?
Because it's exactly, it fits.
A transpose is minus
A. It's anti-symmetric.
Keeps me right on the circle.
OK now, trapezoidal
method keeps me
right on the circle, 32 steps.
And so the picture just shows
where it goes after 32 steps.
And 32, 32 does it
come back there?
Well, not exactly, right?
We don't expect to find
a different solution
to be exactly in sync
with cos(t), the real one.
But it's really close.
I think in that figure
I can see that that's
sort of a double
point there, at 2pi.
I put a little arrow
indicating small phase error.
It misses by a little bit.
And actually, roughly
what does it miss by?
This was the point of the
order of accuracy stuff.
Roughly what size is
that little error?
That's what we did over here.
The term that we got
wrong was a delta t cubed.
At each step.
Can I just tell you the answer?
The error here is of
size delta t squared.
Because over here we
match those series
and we found the error
was delta t cubed.
That's in a single step.
But now we've got one
over delta t steps,
you see what I'm saying?
That if the error was
delta t cubed per step,
and I have one over delta
t steps, to get somewhere,
or 2pi over delta t or whatever,
then that gives me delta t
squared.
So that little error there is my
error of size delta t squared.
And that square tells me
I've got a good method.
At least, decent.
Second order accurate.
And the trapezoidal rule
is sort of the natural one.
Well, OK, so that's a
full hour mostly devoted
to two or three things.
Actually the eigenvectors
came into it.
And the energy
conservation came into it,
the stability matching
series came into it.
And the picture.
OK, I'll see you Friday
for more about these guys,
and then Monday evening
please ask me everything
you want to, on Monday evening.
OK.
Thank you.